[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on this Thursday the 18th
of May
2023 my name is Freddie gray I am the
deputy editor of The Spectator and I
will be your host today
on the show this week we have migration
nation the cover of The Spectator this
week is about the news that the
government is about to announce that
there will be 700 000 net immigrants
into Britain legal immigrants into
Britain this year
Fraser Nelson has written that covered
piece he'll be talking to Nigel farage
who probably needs no introduction we
will then talk about a related subject
which is conservatism and the national
conservative conference which was held
in Westminster this week I'll speak to
two speakers at that conference that's
Mary Harrington of unheard and Tim
Stanley of the telegraph
and after that we'll move to Foreign
Affairs and I'll talk to Paul wood about
evgeny pregozin who is emerging as the
potential rival to Vladimir Putin in
Russia or is he you never know when it
comes to Russia news and lastly I will
talk about artificial intelligence and
dating
which is a very weird weird world I'll
be joined by Jake Kozlowski who runs an
AI dating service called
keeper
before we get going I must thank our
brilliant sponsors can a continuity
wealth management they are experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who offer you unwavering support through
challenging times
visit can do wealth.com for more
information
to begin let me hold up uh this week's
spectator again migration nation is the
cover piece and it's about the news that
the government is expected to soon
announce or even admit that legal
migration net legal migration is
somewhere around 700 000 immigrants
coming into this country uh it's a lot
higher than was expected and Fraser
Nelson explores the possibility that it
may be being used to cover up the large
number of British people who are on
benefits he joins me now to explain his
thesis along with the politician turned
broadcaster Nigel farage
Fraser I think what people find most
striking about your piece is that brexit
seems to have meant more immigration not
less because that was not what we were
told it would do now during the campaign
both the leave and remain campaigns
argue that brexit would mean
significantly less immigration you
couldn't find any economic analysis of
brexit but didn't assume that my net
migration would go down quite
significantly now you heard some people
on the relief campaign were saying you
know what this is what we need fewer
migration and therefore scarce workers
have become more scarce therefore the
salaries go up and on the remain sides
there was a moment where Stewart Rose
the former m s Chief was in question
time and he rather famously said yes and
there'll be fewer migration that means
more content for Laborers and labor
costs will go up and that's not a good
thing so you had the two sides agreeing
on whether it was disagreeing on whether
it was good or bad the end that you
would end up with less migration and
perhaps higher salaries with a low paid
and you could argue yeah people will be
paying more money for the pizza the way
to paid more you know that kind of
argument but nobody disagreed that
brexit would significantly lower
migration and it would be a better way
of managing globalization that they
basically it's got a bit out of control
under the Blair period in many ways
almost the whole point of leaving the EU
was to Take Back Control of Border
policy so we would exit the system of
free movement and being able to decide
how many we'd want what we now find is
when they've taken back control the
government's giving almost 500 000 visas
a year and when you include the students
who nowadays apparently have got one and
two dependents until the number Hits 700
000 or probably more we're going to get
that next week but this isn't an
accident because Richardson neck has now
got complete control you can decide
whether to issue a Visa or not so this
is deliberate policy but one that hasn't
been announced and one that hasn't been
explained and I think it should be well
we should say that by spectator office
standards you are something of a dove on
immigration you'll certainly a dove
compared to the man sitting on your left
but you still find this very troubling
because because of unemployment because
of long-term sickness because of the
fact that a lot of British natives are
in a welfare trap essentially yeah I
think the mass immigration has been
overall quite a stunning success for
Britain and we have had a massive and
demographic change one in five of our
workers now is Fordham born and I think
in London
um half of all children have got an
immigrant mother including I should say
my own three kids I'm contributing to
this phenomenon
um and I think that we've Managed IT in
an incredibly successful way if you look
at the coronation for example a couple
of weeks ago we had a Hindu prime
minister a Buddhist Home Secretary
Muslim mayor of London Muslim first
minister of Scotland and no other
country in the world would you have had
this picture of successful integration
so it pulled off very very well and I
think we continue to pull it off well
we're finding out of either
statisticians that we're getting three
quarters of a million net migration that
hasn't been riots in the streets about
it there's no populist party I mean
while again Nigel was running the brexit
party talking of immigration they were
used to becoming first in the European
elections only a few years ago now there
is nothing nothing to the right of the
conservatives Richard Tyson's lot if you
lived 500 candidates of the locals
they've got something like five or six
candidates through a dreadful success
rate so we don't have any what you might
call anti-immigrant populist party or
anything approaching my description
either in Parliament or in the opinion
polls so the public seemed to be quite
happy with this if there isn't happiness
it hasn't expressed itself politically
now where I'm concerned is I think
although immigration works very well it
can perhaps work too well the Temptation
politically to use this to cover up the
failures of the welfare state is very
great like earlier on this week we had
figures coming out showing 5.3 million
Brits earn out of work benefits we would
really notice this if it wasn't for Mass
immigration because we wouldn't have
anybody to run the economy but when we
can cover it up with mass migration it
works
Nigel you've made some waves this week
by saying that brexit has failed
because of what the government's done
with it yes you know number one we
haven't actually helped business
businesses are leaving we've got a brain
drain going on for the first time since
the 1970s secondly there's an absolute
breach of trust with the electorate over
immigration which is absolutely
perfectly clear the only reason we won
that referendum were people turning out
on Council Estates in the Midlands of
the north thinking you know what this is
the one time my vote can make a
difference and thirdly uh brexit is
failing because it's actually turned out
that our politicians are about as
useless as the European commission now
you know that doesn't mean voting to get
back sovereignty was wrong far from it
but in the minds of ordinary brexit
voters this isn't working and I'd remind
Fraser there were a third group of
people in that referendum uh talking
about immigration those that didn't want
to talk about it at all I remember being
told you know by Hanan and Boris Johnson
no no no no don't discuss immigration in
the referendum we'll lose the referendum
you know some of our very Posh friends
don't like this sort of thing in the end
they were forced to talk about it
reluctantly but they never ever Boris
never intended to reduce the numbers of
people coming into this country so the
First Fundamental question to address is
that breach of faith I think it's very
strong and very real and secondly let me
say this
the electorate assumed with brexit that
immigration had been dealt with
and they're now beginning to understand
that it hasn't been dealt with
and you may well say there's no populist
party in British politics at the moment
there will be it's coming disconnect the
disconnect is bigger now than it was in
2010. I could see in 2010 that the
political media class in London just had
no idea what everybody else in the
country was talking about and I think
we're heading back to that and quite
quickly let's get on to the future of
properties politics in a moment because
I think that's where they should go and
for now it's fair to say polls suggests
that immigration has dipped in in terms
of the issue which voters consider most
important I think it's now fourth or is
it Fifth what if it's not being
discussed that's not surprising I mean
if there is no coverage of the issue and
people don't know what's going on that's
not surprising the reason the reason
that immigration became the big
political issue that it was
is that people in their minds linked it
to membership of the European Union that
was what the ukip surge was all about
that's what you successfully did yes and
it took me years yeah it took me years
to make that connection and I from 2004
I said to all the people working with me
once I can make this connection this
political part is going to a different
place
I think over the course of the next year
or two people will start to make the
connection that the reason there's a
housing crisis is mass immigration the
reason they can't get a GP appointment
is mass immigration the reason their
lives are more miserable than they were
10 years ago their quality of life is
diminishing is because of the population
crisis an explosion in this country but
in what way is it a crisis you're living
in London earning good money living in a
lovely house talking about rich Hindus
who happen to be our prime minister go
out onto the council Estates meet people
I think you'll see the audience you know
my driver my driver my driver's kid
didn't go to school last year the
school's too full 13 years old not at
school right so your driver what you're
saying that the local authorities
refused to provide this child with the
police because they're in education
places that's right it's happening all
over the country doesn't this illegal
for your councils to refuse people no
home education has been given online no
place at schools you go to Lincolnshire
for example you'll find four and a half
five-year-olds maybe 20 miles on a bus
to get to school you there is a
population explosion that is damaging
and diminishing the quality of life of
ordinary folk in this country if you
don't see it now I promise you you will
see but why is it well I can't work out
is this if there is this um this anger
then why hasn't got no political
expression why does um why the reform
party do something incredibly badly just
a few weeks ago if we polled a thousand
people in Stoke on Trent now and asked
who the Reform Party was I wonder how
many would know that it even exists you
know that's the problem you know we may
know because we live in this world
ordinary folk don't know and actually
establishing political movements is not
an easy thing to do and reform is
effectively you know it may be a
follow-on from the brexit party but
effectively it's a new political party
so two things I would say number one the
reason we're not seeing this expressed
more is because it's not been given
voice but it's beginning to be we're
having this National debate now about
numbers and number two there's not a
political leader that people can see at
this moment in time voicing their
concerns once those connections are made
between I mean everything even travel
even travel even even the length of
Journeys potholes in the roads these are
all symptoms of a population crisis and
it's going to dominate British politics
over the next 10 years is it not a
problem then if as you say for because
of brexit well brexit came about because
people linked the European Union of mass
migration now people will say well we've
had brexit and we still have mass
migration no we don't know what they'll
say is they lied to us yeah they lied to
us but maybe they wanted control over
immigration and that's the big
difference can it build it to United
before there was probably no control
um free movement that's what it means
right you cannot draw it now right now
if you look at this coming in there are
different people but not the pools the
Indians are now number one Follow The
Thing by Australians then you have
Nigerians then you have Americans now to
get a visa for this country you need to
be over a certain salary threshold you
need to speak English you need to be
getting a job in a certain profession
this was
wait a second I got a second
I mean the salary criteria
when Australia does this it says we're
short of Engineers we're short of people
in these sectors we will open up spaces
in this sector in nearly every single
case those that go to Australia are
earning more than the average wage what
this government have done is they've
lowered the thresholds the most
unimaginable levels where actually the
threshold to come in is eight to ten
thousand pounds lower than the average
wage that's why the numbers are where
they are they have deliberately
engineered this and of course they've
got their big business friends
encouraging it but equally as you point
out in your article there is this
massive welfare is a problem of 5.3
million people and it appears at the
minute that no political party's got the
courage to take that on so it's all well
and good to say you have to pass these
tests to come in but we've set the
threshold so low in terms of
qualifications and income as if as for
it to almost be meaningless maybe this
is making it more palatable though maybe
that is why when there's a recent poll
asking people all over the world what do
you think of immigration Britain emerged
as the most Pro country in the world
other than I think Norway and I wonder
if that's because we see the migration
differently now now the brexit has come
along we know that to get a Visa you
need a job nobody's really talking about
lazy foreigners who aren't really you
know these are people who are by and
large more likely to work and then Brits
now nobody was ever talking about lazy
foreigners that was never the argument
the argument was about wage compression
the argument was about difficulties
getting onto social housing lists the
argument was about fundamental changes
in community the argument was about the
fact well why is never speaking English
a mystery they were very very different
arguments and they were arguments very
firmly rooted around Community around
family and of course the ironic social
conservatism of so many labor voters you
know which actually is still there I
mean you know those red wall voters are
surprisingly small C conservative and
patriotic people in many many ways so no
I think that the idea that well we've
got back control we've chosen not to use
it but we've got control so we're all
happy is I think it's for the birds
friends
I mean you've focused a lot on illegal
migration in your in Immigration yeah in
your journalism and so on yes uh do you
think the fact that that is such a media
uh preoccupation distracts from the the
issue of legal migration which as you
say is the reason I did that the reason
I went on this illegal immigration thing
back in sort of late 19 early 20s is
because nobody else wanted to talk about
it was literally being buried under the
carpet so I thought well I'm going to
you know cause a bit of noise on this
and get because it was obvious to me in
2020 there were numbers that came would
explode because virtually nobody was
being deported anywhere else and you can
come in be put in a hotel you still and
you literally stay in a four-star hotel
and go to work every day in the black
economy and earn cash it's happening all
over the country so I pushed that
because I wanted it I wanted it to
become a big issue also because you know
my fear from 2015. and the reason that I
use that Breaking Point poster that's so
upset the Metropolitan Elite is that the
EU have made the same mistake with the
Mediterranean
um and I feared
I feared that unless we got a grip
through brexit that we'd face a similar
wave now it may not be the same
numerically but symbolically the boat's
crossing the English channelism but the
way the numbers that are crossed into
Europe so far across the Met is trouble
last year so there's more of this coming
but ironically yes everyone's now become
so focused on what's been happening
illegally with 45 46 000 people last
year that you're right it's it's it's
it's kind of stopped us talking yes
about legal net numbers I remember you
accepted an award at The Spectators
parliamentarian of the Year Awards a few
years ago and you said you'll never hear
from me again okay
well I have to ask you do you think
there's obviously a space opening up to
the right of Richard now particularly on
the issue of immigration will you be
going back I think it's I think it's
bigger than that I think the absolute
betrayal of the five and a half million
men and women who were sole Traders and
self-employed I mean you can't believe
the anger in that Community out there
they loathe the conservative party they
fear labor will be even worse but they
load the conservative party the complete
lack of understanding of how the ir35
rules in practice are working in the
building industry Etc so it isn't just
on immigration there is a I think the
sense of detachment
the the conversations that are happening
in Westminster are so far removed from
older people's lives I mean what I
campaign with the brexit party in 2019
quite successfully we got rid of Mrs May
and I'm rather proud of that but the
slogan we campaigned on wasn't even
about brexit it was change politics for
good there was a hope and a feeling that
a different kind a more engaged kind of
politics would come from brexit none of
that's happened so they asked you a
question is very simple
the Gap that is opening up
in British Politics on the center right
um is potentially bigger than it was
with UK yeah I mean I mean it's a very
very big gap you very skillfully didn't
listen to the second part about my
question which is will you try and fill
that game I haven't finished yet sorry
give me a moment I was ignoring you I
can be accused of many things ignoring
questions so the potential is there and
something or someone at some point is
going to fill it you know I I sort of
call it an anger Gap
now it depends who fills that anger Gap
I hope and believe what I did before was
a positive way of filling it by saying
let's get our sovereignty back as a
means of dealing with these problems
before I came along the already came to
prominence the anger Gap was being
filled by Nick Griffin and it's very
easy to forget between 2005 and 2010 the
extent to which the BMP were laying down
Roots you know in those Northern Town
councils Etc
I I haven't decided what I'm going to do
I mean I'll be honest with you
um
I I do feel
that a large chunk of the country
deserves some representation and
deserves a voice
equally
um I still pretty bruised by the 2015
general election how can you get four
million votes in one seat it makes it a
very difficult thing to do
I I haven't decided what I'm going to do
but something's going to come along if
it's not me it'll be it'll be a Nick
Griffin Mark too you know we will we
will have a rise of something way out on
the right it's happening as we speak all
over Europe albeit aided by
proportion representation system
something is going to change something
is going to crack and I think
coming back to UK politics uh you know I
think I've got a better understanding of
those Rebel voters than than pretty much
anybody frankly
um they were the people that were the
backbone that built ukip up into being a
major party in British politics
and if the conservative party on its
current course thinks he's got any
chance of winning a single one of those
seats that that I'm afraid they're
deluded the only thing that might save
us is this the one thing the
conservative party is really good at is
survival you know it's been around for a
couple of hundred years it exists to
attempt to get power and to hold power
so they've still got time I guess if
they chose to be genuinely radical but I
can't see it happen by radical you mean
cutting a number of visas issued versus
your definition because the funny thing
is we've just had local elections and
how many parties are various Stripes not
a sign not a sniff of the sort of anger
that you're talking about because
is it real or might it be because
there's no way but but that was like
that that was the same effectively
before 2010 you know other than the BMP
you were just selling it I think Griffin
was getting a huge number palpable anger
then the BMP in the north but they had a
big presence
at the moment if you want to vote that
way there's nobody giving a voice to it
that's the Gap in the market but it
looks like a lot of those verses are
going back to labor now yes I've met
them this weekend yeah I've met them
this week why do you think they're going
back to it is it because Kirsten was
talking to the right on some things no I
just I think this Tory party they don't
identify with these conservative
politicians at all they briefly did with
Boris for a bit he seemed rather fun uh
he seemed rather normal identify with
cure Stone right no not really so why
are they going back to labor because
they're tribal labor that's where they
come from they've been their families
have voted labor since 1918. you know
the the sort of the gateway drug
of ukip and the brexit party took them
to the conservatives in 2019 and that
was on a brexit let's get this thing
sorted out let's get back control of our
borders
um but they're going back to labor
because that's where they're from
and the concern and and I think there's
also a profound sense of disappointment
that the brexit thing has not worked out
the way they really wanted it to
I think we'll wrap it up there but uh
thank you very much thank you for coming
in and thank you very much for talking
about your cover please
now speaking of opportunities opening up
on the political right there's been a
big conference in London this week in
Westminster the national conservatism
conference which is a an American Import
um but starred lots of Tory MPS and
various conservative figures from the
anglo-american community
um and two of the speakers at that
conference join me now
um Tim Stanley of the Telegraph and Mary
Harrington of unheard
um Tim perhaps you could start by
telling our viewers a little bit about
what national conservatism is what this
particular movement is and what they're
trying to do and could you also tell us
whether they succeeded in doing it in
London this week
put it to me brilliantly that this
conference was a seminar masquerading as
a rally
so some academics put on a seminar in
the center of London they invited
politicians and the politicians then
turned it into a platform to make it a
debate about the future of the
conservative party so to back up a
little bit there is an academic who's
Israeli called uran hazoni who is an
expert on conservative political Theory
a little bit of Zionism blended with
some
nationalism with some American
exceptionalism and of course he's got a
profound interest in Britain as well
because Britain is the home of
Enlightenment era conservative thinking
and has only wrote a couple of books
about conservatism and about nationalism
and came up with this uh well I wouldn't
say I want to say came up with the idea
it's been around for a while but he he
helped to uh to make concrete this idea
that at the center of conservative
thinking should be the life of the
nation not the individual not free
markets not getting rich but actually
making your country a better happier
healthier place it's about re-routing
the individual within their community
uh he also argues that because it's
about the nation conservatism will look
different from one place to another
it's National conservatism has managed
to get a big intellectual audience in
the United States it's got some money
behind it and they have been traveling
the world for the last couple of years
holding conferences in various places uh
they've been I think to Italy they've
been to Belgium they've been to America
and now they're here in Britain and in
each case the reaction and the response
has been different and the nature of the
conference has been different in a way
that reflects that idea that
conservatism will vary from one country
to another
so as I said National conservatism came
to London they invited politicians and
they happened to do so at a moment in
which the conservative party is cracking
up and uh a sort of a section of the
Parliamentary conservative party which
is socially conservative I'd say quite a
quite a small section and which is
grouped around sowella Braverman took
this as an opportunity to get a platform
to lay out their ideas about nationhood
and of course probably in this country
right now the most potent conservative
national issue is immigration and that
was the one that came up repeatedly but
as I say there's a slight tension
between what some of us were there to do
at the conference which was to share
ideas discuss hazoni's work provide
criticism and there was a lot of
criticism as well and what politicians
did which was turn up and make speeches
that got headlines which was fantastic
for building the brand of national
conservatism because even though uh it's
not terribly well known and a lot of
people still don't know who Professor
hazoni is uh that phrase is now on
everyone's lips in Westminster
Mary you were talking about biology and
feminism and not Party politics do you
agree with Tim that though I mean I
thought perhaps it was I came and saw
some of your speeches uh I thought it
was a shame in a way that this sort of
potentially quite interesting subject to
debate obviously controversial Liberty
makes headlines and so on but it did
also become a sort of uh it felt a bit
like Tory Party Conference the the
right-wing version
perhaps a little bit I mean my sense
um from
from spending some time in the in the
breakout conversations and and really in
the in the speeches as well is that
there are great many parallels with
um with with some of the national
conservatives and conferences that I've
attended elsewhere actually and on on
this in the sense that if you if you
have a conversation about conservative
invariant conservatism invariably there
are going to be some politicians there
and politicians are going to politics
that's what they do
um so invariably you're going to get
some stunt speeches and you're going to
get some people who are thinking very
concretely about how this is going to
place your electorates and and really
singing singing a tune in that key
um but there are a great many other
reasons to attend a conference like that
and one of the things that came across
very clearly to me was that there's a
much as much as I've written about this
before much as on other similar
occasions even elsewhere there's there's
quite a noticeable difference between
the way they typically typically older
politicians making stunt speeches are
thinking about these questions and and
the way some of the younger attendees of
which there are surprisingly many I mean
when I I was when I 20 years ago if you
went to a conservatism event it was
mostly sort of across the old buffers in
corduroy and there was a sense that you
get in some Anglican provincial Anglican
churches that there's really nobody
there under pretty much under retirement
age and that it wasn't like that at all
I think something like 40 of the
attendees at the event in London that
just finished were under 30.
um you know start uh really for a for a
conservative event a surprising number
of them were students I spoke to a great
many 22 23 year old young men and women
who are really grappling with you know
the big questions and I think and there
was a there was a very noticeable Gulf
between the way those young people were
approaching these questions and the way
the stump speech makers who who are
really engaging with a Westminster
political audience were were approaching
these questions now I think it's it's
good and healthy and right that we're
going to have different approaches and
different different priorities you know
within within an overall umbrella but it
was it was very interesting to bring
those groups together and to begin to
tease out where some of those some of
those blind spots are and I think there
are there's potentially some some
reflection to be done on on that on
those gaps
um that that might be beneficial overall
to people within Westminster going
forward
Tim you've written a lot about American
politics and I'm sure you've been to uh
American conferences like that about
conservatism and there's there's a lot
of that in America you know with the
conservatism is a big question that the
right has been asking itself for ages do
you think it suits uh British tourism to
have these uh sort of sometimes quite
intellectualized conversations does is
it something that American movement
conservatives and can sort of adapt into
British conservatism
yeah a lot of the media pounced on the
idea that this is an American Import and
even an American infiltration and
takeover of the conservative party uh
but Freddie you've been to U.S
conferences and as you know they always
begin uh with smoke machines with the
eye of the tiger
and with a woman and a man coming out
and saying hi thank you for coming whoa
there was none of that in fact there
were barely any American speakers uh and
indeed there was a great deal of media
misrepresentation of the conference and
the people who spoke at it uh this was
in some regards one of the most
multi-ethnic Multicultural
multi-religious conferences that I have
been to in this country and some of the
speakers who attacked for individual
things they said so the speaker who said
we're not having enough babies was a
woman
um Sue Ella Braven and the speaker who
said we need to do more to control
immigration is a person of color uh
yoram hazoni uh is himself Israeli there
were a large number of Jewish delegates
there so so the idea that this this was
some kind of right-wing
ethno-nationalist thing I found really
quite Preposterous and was based upon
one or two tweets which were put out by
the by the organization's media team who
obviously themselves took no offense at
those particular tweets
um but does this is this does this go
down well well I think if they don't do
this there's really nothing else uh
you're right by the infrastructurally in
America there are things like Heritage
which do this sort of conference all the
time and they bring people from across a
very much larger country who wouldn't
otherwise not meet and they get to share
ideas and they get to promote
candidacies and things like that
um we hadn't really been doing that in
Britain and that helps to explain why
there's a paucity of fresh ideas and
some of the ideas coming out of this
conference we really went against the
grain of British conservative thinking
and in some ways the conference was more
left-wing than it was reported and was
understood so for example Danny Krueger
gave a speech where again people jumped
upon the fact that he referred to the
normative family we can have a debate
about whether or not that is an accurate
or fair or kind description of families
but if you read the other 99 of the
speech he was essentially saying that
many of the problems of Britain are down
to conservative economics and have been
down to the legacy of thatcherism and
individualism and atomization so
actually some of the speakers at this
conference are on a journey towards the
left not towards the right and it was
very frustrating that people didn't look
beyond the tweets and actually noticed
that
Mary do you not think this has been
talked about in in the media and in uh
perhaps highbrow circles at the right
you could call them uh for a long time
uh post-liberalism red tourism blue
labor there's a there's an there's long
been a feeling that something new has
got to happen in politics Beyond uh the
the you know the Thatcher Reagan
neoliberalism if you like that's not a
great word for it but I think that's
what most people use and yet it never
really has materialized beyond the odd
conference the odd sort of moment where
people get excited about it it doesn't
really speak to electorates
I think you're right I mean it's it's
too early to tell I think as as a
Chinese Premier once said about the
French Revolution whether or not it
worked it's it's too early to tell
whether this is never going to
materialize one of the things actually I
thought was interesting about the the
really very strong media reaction and I
and I agree with Tim when he says that I
think it's been that there have been
some bad faith representations of what
was discussed I mean one of the one of
the standout speeches for me wasn't was
an economist who was making the case
that capitalism is structurally
antenatalist and this is not simply an
effect of bad policy this is not simply
an effective you know real factualism
has never been tried this is structural
and
and they and they're they're great many
other social ills that it propagates
besides which is a profoundly profoundly
left-wing idea and I think the The
Thinker that was referenced most
frequently in that speech was Karl Marx
and this is not something that the
guardian is ever going to report about
National conservatives and Conference
because it just doesn't compute but I
think one of the things that was that
was interesting about this conference
and about the very intense and sometimes
bad faith media representation of it is
that up until now as you say
post-liberal ideas or you know this sort
of caucus of I did the upper right hand
quadrant I think as as the Nerds call it
you know the economically left and and
socially right
um quadrant of ideas has been sort of
kicking around amongst politics nerds
for some time
um but has hasn't has yet to gain any
sort of mainstream traction I think part
of the issue there is that there has
been a great deal of um
amongst the respectable people it's
there's a certain amount of effort
that's gone into making sure that those
ideas are non-you and in as much as they
appear at all and it's they've been
they've been fairly methodically coded
as low status and there's not there's
just not something that ever gets
discussed amongst respectable people in
in zone one it just doesn't happen and I
think part of the reason the media's
been so upset about this conference is
that this that's just not manifesty not
the case you know here's a conference
where really those ideas are being
discussed and it's happening in
Westminster
um and and furthermore there are there
are some quite there are some household
names there and so and so in that sense
I mean it it's probably too early to
tell whether any whether it really this
is just going to end up being recouped
as some critics from the right have
suggested by you know the sort of
neoliberalism in a in a fancy dress you
know with some with neoliberalism plus
culture war is the worst case scenario
really you know that this this just gets
recouped and we get more of the same
with with occasional diatribes about
work
um but it's it's too early to tell
otherwise whether it's going to go that
way or whether in fact some of the some
of the more interesting thinking and the
more creative thinking which which I I
agree is still is still Fringe relative
to the stump speech stuff but there's
there's still a chance that some of that
might percolate through
um and and I think it's if it does so it
will be in the teeth of all the
respectable people working very hard to
code it as low status and there's just
not something which is even within the
Overton window but the fact that this
conference happened in Westminster was a
it was a fairly a fairly forceful shove
against the parameters of the Overton
window and I think that's a that's a
positive step it really is Tim we just
had Nigel farage uh on spectator TV and
he was talking about
um how the Tory party always survives
somehow because uh despite uh the fact
it's probably going to face uh an
election loss in in the coming months uh
do you think look at the way British
Tory politicians treated this conference
do you think the conservative party is
going to adapt to this movement
um or is it going to shun it how is it
going to adapt and survive
some of the biggest pushback against the
conference came from what you might call
liberal conservatives many of whom did
not attend it didn't pay attention to
what was said I was just out on a side
note by the way I was struck by the
things that were not discussed at this
conference no one said bring back the
British Empire no one said ban abortion
there's a whole host of old issues which
are totally off the table now and
everyone's moved on from and yet they're
the things that there's often an
assumption right-wingers are saying and
they're simply not part of their
narrative at all anymore but there was a
big pushback among liberal conservatives
who are very powerful influential within
the party that said I think a way away
from the conference there is a growing
and influential group of people who feel
that the economic policy approach has
been wrong we need more industrial
policy I wouldn't say protectionism
versus free trade that's a very that's a
silly way of simplifying it but there's
a sense that there's got to be a move
away from the idea that the job of
government is simply to get out the way
and and that I think is the most
significant shift in conservative things
and you might even find it among some
liberal conservatives some Tories are
starting to say we have an idea of how
people ought to be living they should be
having families they should be buying
homes but the economic situation doesn't
actually allow them to do that so how do
we create the material circumstances
under which people can do those things
uh and some of that might involve
creative government action now they're
so fought to give a concrete example uh
the debate around the best way to do
child care we all know that one reason
why people are not having children well
when people are not settling down is
because of the extortionate cost of
raising a child and now I think almost
everyone's recognized that within the
conservative party that that's a failing
and that's a failure that's happened
under the Tories the debate is should it
be through the state sponsoring child
care where you leave your kid with
someone or as people like Miriam Cates
and some of the national conservatives
would prefer the state making it more
making it easier for women to stay at
home and raise the child themselves so
there's a cultural Clash over what do
women want but actually I think
conservatives are coming around to the
idea that there are areas of policy that
government has to take an interest in
even if it starts to sound a bit like
socialism because if they don't do it
you end up with a very unconservative
outcome which is people not having
babies or dropping out of the workforce
which is bad for the hallowed word
growth
where you you spoke about uh women the
body biology uh but I noticed there
wasn't a lot of talk about the NHS or
the National Health Service do you think
that's because it's not a policy
um conference it's a it's an ideas
conference or do you think it's because
nobody really wants to tackle the NHS on
the right one way or the other
it's a very interesting question you
know I hadn't actually it hadn't
actually struck me until you pointed it
out just now that nobody was really
talking about the NHS at the conference
but you're absolutely right nobody was
talking about the NHS and to be honest I
think it's almost certainly the case
that nobody is tackling it because it's
just too big it's just too big and and
it touches on too much stuff I mean I I
forget who it was who quit that you know
we're now a Health Service with a sort
of vestigial country attached and there
is a there is a sense of that and nobody
nobody quite knows what to do about it
and I mean I think in as much as it was
referenced it was probably obliquely
um in the several several talks actually
who spoke about the impossibility of
continuing an abundant welfare state
with a collapsing population which is
which is the the existential issue for a
lot of things and is an extremely
uncomfortable Wicked problem
um when you start looking at the
Confluence of you know the where where
social solidarity converges with high
taxation converges with support for the
welfare state support converges with
population
growth or shrinkage you know there's a
real Wicked problem there which which
we're already confronting I mean if
you're unless you're unless you're
pregnant or very old where I live in a
small town in small town England you
know you can you you'll be lucky if you
get a GP appointment within six weeks
that's just that's just the reality in a
lot of places now
um if it's if people are if if people
weren't talking about it almost
certainly just because it's too big and
too radioactive I mean you can't you
can't do it in a 15-minute speech and
and people people are trying to but
maybe trying to zoom out a little bit
and thinking about the structural
questions which have brought us to the
point where where a Health Service with
a vestigial country attached and and
trying trying a few different angles to
see if we can see if we can come at some
of those some of those thorny issues
from from different perspectives and
find creative ways of thinking about it
Tim you made uh the point of yours but
you did mention the National Health
Service because you said that people who
are uncomfortable with the national in
National conservatism should should
think about the National Health Service
yeah yeah obviously people are
uncomfortable about the word national
being involved being attached to a
political label because in their mind uh
it all typically goes to national
socialism and I joked that uh if that is
the case then we're also going to crack
down on the National Trust the nspcc and
the NHS
um but Mary's right the NHS didn't come
up I think that's partly because this is
an academic audience because there was
some transatlantic crossover and it's
not a debate which I think some of our
guests would have particularly
understood or enjoyed in the same way
that I'm I'm not sure if you had this
kind of conference it would have been
appropriate to discuss Medicare and the
very particular debates around health
insurance in the United States the other
issue we did not discuss is Ukraine
which I think was partly a conscious
decision by the conference uh because if
you open up a conversation about Ukraine
I don't think you'd get anyone who says
Vladimir Putin's great but you're always
terrified someone's going to turn up to
speak who is Russian adjacent right uh
who is sympathetic in some way uh and I
think there's a little bit of political
control there the conference didn't want
to go down that rabbit hole but I think
it might also just be that uh there's
another issue that we didn't discuss
because it's not something that's part
of the British rights vocabulary There
is almost 99.9 support for Ukraine among
British conservatives and so there was
no real need to touch it because we are
pretty much United on that subject well
uh it's not that I don't want to go down
that rabbit hole but we do have to wrap
that up so um thank you very much Tim
and thank you Mary
[Music]
today's Trailblazers
now if you've been reading the news
about the war in Ukraine you've probably
come across the name evgeny pregotin
he is the leader of the Wagner group The
Mercenary group that Russia is using for
its fight in Ukraine and he is also
known as Putin's Chef or at least he was
but the two men appear and we stress the
word appear to have Grown Apart in
recent days and pragosan has been quite
critical and he's also emerging it seems
as a Potential Threat to Putin's
Authority
to discuss this interesting figure I'm
joined Now by Paul wood who is a former
world affairs correspondent for the BBC
and he's also working on a very long
profile of pragosin Paul let's start
with the uh basic question who is
evgenie forgotten
well in a curious way he reminds me of
another figure that we're both quite
obsessed about and that is Donald Trump
the personality is quite trumpian he's
full of bombast bombast he doubles down
whenever he's confronted he's a master
at trolling just like Trump and this is
quite important when it comes to taking
or not taking his statements at face
value
the big difference is that while a lot
of people assume Trump is a criminal
pregogin actually was a criminal he got
convicted of some quite serious offenses
in his youth he did some burglaries age
18 then while he was on a suspended
sentence he did a lot more burglaries
and him and a gang a gang that he
appeared to lead
um snuck up on this uh poor woman
pragodin choked her this is according to
testimony from others in the gang he's
always denied it but according to the
testimony he choked her while somebody
else pulled her boots off and then as
she fell unconscious to the ground he
pulled her earrings off so for that he
got 10 years in a Soviet prison and
Soviet prisons are not like nice
friendly gentle British prisons or even
American prisons these are penal
colonies huge barracks-like structures
where these are really quite rough
places now he survived and apparently
prospered in this environment to emerge
just as the Soviet Union was undergoing
perestroika and then of course
it collapsed and Leningrad becomes from
Petersburg and some Petersburg is the
wild west if Chicago was somebody put it
to me and he manages to start a very
successful restaurant business there
first he starts with hot dogs hot dogs
are not apparently widely sold in Saint
Petersburg at the time then he moves on
to luxury restaurants and then he has
his big break which is that the deputy
mayor of Saint Petersburg who happens to
be Vladimir Putin comes in one day and
likes the food and then decides to bring
his important guests George Bush
President W bush twice for instance and
this all sounds quite trivial and he's
got this absurd nickname Putin chef but
um as one analyst explained it to me if
it's some Petersburg in the early 90s
and everything's uh just a little bit
rackety and there isn't even a reliable
food supply but Putin can show his
foreign guests look we can put on this
huge show of of magnificent food and
there's a bit of pageantry and there's a
bit of theater that was actually quite
an important function for pragosian but
of course people who know this in
Petersburg restaurants in the 80s say
well you'd also had to been pretty well
connected in the criminal world to
survive there and to get your food
supply and not to have to give over all
your
um profits and takings uh your um
profits and protection money
so this is this is the figure that
everybody knows at Putin's Chef he
becomes the kremlin's caterer and off
the back of that he becomes the caterer
to the entire Russian army and becomes a
billionaire
and then this thing called the Wagner
group emerges and it's all very
mysterious nobody knows why it's called
the Wagner group one theory is that an
early field commander a man called
Dmitry udkin loved Wagner for his love
of the Volk and and this idea of a
resurgent nationalism that may or may
not be true who knows
um several figures called udkin have
popped up and there's a suspicion
relayed to me by some Petersburg
journalist that forgotten is actually
finding people called udkin and making
them employees of Wagner just so he can
perpetuate this idea of a figure called
udkin who's somehow related to it all
another Masterpiece of trolling but
during all this time
um pregosian gave almost no media
interviews he gave one talking about the
hot dog stall and he always denied
having anything to do with Wagner did he
Sue journalists for it until suddenly in
September of last year he emerges as
this very important figure in the war
which brings us right up to date the
British Ministry of Defense thinks that
50 000 Wagner office are fighting in
Ukraine or were at the height of it and
they're really quite important for the
war effort and this has propelled
pragosian who has no official position
in Russia
um into the very front rank of the
people fighting this war he might even
be after Putin the face of the war in
Ukraine the Russian face of the war
and he's presenting himself uh as a
military figure which is does he have
any military background before this war
other than the fact that he led the
Baldwin group does he have any military
training or anything
well as far as we know the only uniform
he ever wore was a prison uniform
um but over many years the Wagner group
were active uh when the Ukraine war
started in 2014-2015 they've been in
Syria they've been in Congo he likes to
appear in full battle dress in uh flak
jacket and Helmut there are no Badges of
rank there and certainly he has no
official position and he's been involved
in an extraordinary Public Power
struggle with the Russian Ministry of
Defense these things normally take place
behind closed doors in the Kremlin but
he's been publicly attacking them
um even appearing to criticize Putin
although we can get into that in a
minute I don't don't really buy it
nobody can really get away with
criticizing Putin
and one there's a a former MI6 officer
in London who prepares reports for
private clients on Russia and he showed
me one of those reports a few months ago
now which said there's only one topic of
of conversation in the upper east of the
Kremlin that's what to do with the
progression problem uh and this former
MI6 officer was claiming there was
several active plots to assassinate him
which sounds like something out of a
spinal but a number of Russian officials
have taken unfortunate falls out of
their balconies on the fifth or sixth
floor so this is not a known in Russian
politics
so he he's certainly skirting a very
dangerous area in these public
pronouncements but whether this is
sanctioned by Putin and Putin running
things you have this image of the sort
of Mafia Dawn encouraging his employees
to be of each other's throats in order
to get the maximum out of them that
could be what's going on here as well
well let's go with that working theory
that it is somehow these criticisms of
Russia are somehow sanctioned by Putin
what would be the thinking there would
it be to to tie into a western narrative
about Russian disharmony as a sort of
smoke screen for actual military
advances
um pick your theory really
um
Steve Bannon the American political
consultant had a way of describing how
he dealt with the media which is flood
the Zone with I think that's what
precaution is doing one of the things I
left out of the truncated biography at
the beginning is the fact that he was
the guy running the so-called troll
Factory in 2016 which put out fake news
onto Facebook and other places uh
allegedly to throw the election for
Donald Trump although you look at what
they put out and it was both for Trump
and against Trump flood the Zone with
confuse the electorate undermine
the legitimacy of the process
so it could be that that's going on it
could be that Putin you know who is in a
losing War wants to embarrass the
ministry of Defense into doing certain
things it could be as simple as
they don't the ministry of Defense the
the defense minister the chief of staff
don't like this upstart precaution
haven't as pregosian claims given him
the ammunition he needs and he is
desperate to do something about it the
the surface explanation might be the
correct explanation uh we simply don't
know
um somebody described to me what
pregosian wants as somebody who knows
pregocian but it's only a theory that he
wants to step into the role
um uh vacated by the far right
politician Vladimir jaronovsky who died
last year which is kind of a licensed
Court Jester you say these extreme
things and everybody knows they're
extreme but then Putin can point to you
and say look if if not me this is the
alternative and so precaution is
licensed to do a lot of things which
will get other people thrown into jail
and bear in mind people are being thrown
into jail in Russia for criticizing the
war and that technically private
military companies mercenary groups are
illegal in Russia and yet this is a man
supplying 50 000 mercenaries to the
front lineup crane so
um
I'm not sure he's gone Rogue I think
this is a kind of Rogue Behavior that's
licensed yeah we should apologize uh
about Steve Bannon not your language
Steve bannon's language to spectator TV
viewers yeah I'm sorry quoting Mr Bannon
um
another another set of reports have come
out suggesting that bregozin was
attempting to strike deals with the
ukrainians
um for strategic Advantage but again do
you think that could be fake news on the
Ukrainian side it's very hard to know
what to believe about anything in this
world yeah I mean there's a lot of fake
news on both sides and the story you're
talking about here is that pragosan
allegedly offered to give away Russian
positions of the army not his own
fighters in order for the ukrainians to
seize uh to cede bakmut this town that
has been at the center of a grinding War
of Attrition and very high losses by the
wagon group for many months
so some background here somebody who
knows precaution told me his ambition is
to enter politics but to do that he has
to come away from Ukraine with something
looking like a victory there was another
town which the Russians um managed to
seize back from the Ukrainian counter
offensive a few months ago prakashian
tried to take the credit there but it
wasn't credible because regular Russian
troops were involved so he kind of said
that he was going to take bakmut and
Bachman was his and there were no other
army forces there so he kind of has to
take this town if he's going to be
credible it has no strategic value they
could just go around it it's purely or
it appears to be purely about giving
precautions something he can call a
victory so if all of that is true and he
really needs this and he's prepared to
sacrifice the lives of his men to do it
then perhaps it is credible he'd make
this offer and after all he doesn't
really care so much about the regular
Russian troops if you believe people
around him but on the other hand could
be Ukrainian propaganda could be
propaganda from the Russian Ministry of
defense against precaution could be
progression Zone propaganda who knows I
mean trust no one believe nothing if um
if if it is sanctioned by Beauty in this
this road Behavior does that suggest
that uh butane burgosian have uh on
Putin and the Wagner group have a better
understanding than Putin in the Army and
that in fact that's the split there is
between the ministry of defense and
Putin and and Wagner group
when the Wagner group is useful in a
number of ways one they were allowed
into prisons to recruiting does have a
lot of credibility with prisoners he can
say as he did say look I was you once
and look at me now I'm a hold of the
hero of of Russia metal you you too
could follow in my footsteps
and he did manage to recruit a lot of
people 40 or 50 000 of them uh to go to
Ukraine
um there's another way that wagon is
useful for the Kremlin which is the line
of command isn't clear if if somebody
from Wagner commits war crimes or they
seem you know some of them are not the
most upstanding citizens to have been
doing a lot of raping a lot of killing a
lot of looting somebody does that or
even if there's a large-scale massacre
which carried out for strategic reasons
and at the beginning of the war it
appears the Russians were literally
trying to terrify the ukrainians into a
rapid collapse of morale and a rapid
surrender all of those things are much
easier to deny if it's irregular forces
I mean everybody assumes it's pretty
fredbear deniability everybody assumes
that Wagner is getting its orders and
its money and its weapons from the
Russian States but you can't it's more
difficult to prove so those are two very
useful functions that are already taking
place it doesn't mean they're the main
part of the war effort and presumably
the actual generals and the actual
minister of defense is quite resentful
of all this
um this just seems to be how Putin runs
the Kremlin I once spoke to a former
Russian intelligence Colonel who said
you know it's like a medieval court with
with different sort of Barons and and
Putin sets them against each other or
like as I said a mafia Dawn where the
boss says I want this to be done and he
just lets people get on with it and the
person who comes back having done it
gets certain rewards in future that may
be what we're seeing here or it could be
that pregozian is just as crazy as he
looks and it's certainly crazy in
Putin's Russia to even appear to be
criticizing Putin and some of his com
comments recently well not naming Putin
but seem to have been skirting on trying
to blame people right at the very top
and that is very dangerous for bigrojan
because even though he's got this Army
he doesn't pay the wages the wages come
through the Kremlin the wages come
through one of the intelligence agencies
it's not like he's got 10 000 or 30 000
brand shirts who are personally loyal to
him that he can call to Moscow and even
if he did there are a lot of forces in
Moscow at President Putin's behest so um
I I don't buy and a lot of people I've
spoken to don't buy this claim that he's
challenging Putin and could be the next
Russian president he's challenging the
people below Putin for Putin's favor so
you don't think I mean a lot of people
would have said the same about Donald
Trump in in 2012 2013 written off you
don't think we could be seeing a
trump-like figure uh emerges Putin's
successor
well perhaps his most significant asset
is not these tens of thousands of of
Fighters but it's the hundreds of
thousands of Fanboys and fan girls on
social media that Wagner has built I
mean it's quite frightening if you look
at for instance reverse side of the
medal which is a telegram and Twitter
Channel
um where people who appear to be
fighting in Ukraine post these videos of
themselves in Ukraine and then lots of
people in Russia say how wonderful it is
and that presumably is an electoral
asset for precaution if you did run for
national office or tried to get into the
Duma it's presumably a fundraising asset
indeed I've been told they've already
been raising funds some of which have
gone to Ukraine but the big difference
between Russia and and the United States
is that that you can do all this in
Russia and somebody will still push you
out of a balcony if you get too big for
your boots
um so I think that precaution can only
remain as a national figure it can only
enter the Doomer or take over a
political party or even take over some
Petersburg which is one of the things
it's allegedly trying to do you can only
do that with Putin say so Paul wood
thank you very much for coming on to
spectator TV
now barely a day goes by without a news
story about how AI or artificial
intelligence is going to disrupt
something massive uh in our society
um we had an interesting piece on
spectator life this week suggesting that
AI is in the process of disrupting
dating apps and will particularly unseat
Tinder which is the giant of dating apps
I'm delighted to be joined by Jake
Kozlowski who is the co-founder of a
dating app that uses AI called keeper
um Jake tell us a little bit about
keeper and how AI can enhance online
dating
definitely
um so Keeper at a super high level you
know you you called it a dating app we
actually uh we we like to talk about it
as a family formation app not a dating
app
um the reason for that is uh you know
dating apps are great for get getting
you on dates for for uh you know helping
you meet new people but that's not
actually the goal that most people have
right most people don't want a a Litany
of dates uh they don't want to spend all
their Time dating what they want to do
um and even match group who owns Tinder
has released surveys that that back up
this claim they really want is just to
find that one person that they want to
spend the rest of their life with and
start a family with right 81 of of gen
Z's uh uh say that that's their top goal
right now um is is in terms of the
dating landscape is to you know find a
long-term committed relationship in this
year
um and so keeper is built all around
that we're we're not a dating product or
a product that you uses AI to introduce
you to that one person who is the most
ideal fit for you in every Dimension
that you have and so we use AI to do it
a traditional Matchmaker would do
basically learn about who you are as a
person both physically personality wise
you know everything about you your
preferences and then disambiguate you
with all the other people in our
database and see okay you know who is
the absolute strongest fit on every
Dimension every preference completely
open-ended that you tell us and then we
introduce you to that person once we
have them so it's a very different
experience than you know here's 10 000
profiles swipe right or left and based
on like photos and a couple couple lines
of text it's interesting you say that
about gen Z because I suppose that
suggests again that that generation and
moving away from what we think young
people are supposed to do which is play
the field uh have a fun time trying to
figure out who's right for them and so
on
for sure I mean I you know I I think uh
there's a couple components to this
covid definitely
um uh gave a lot of people uh feelings
of isolation and loneliness and so it's
sort of uh you know there's been a
reaction to that of like a realization I
guess among the younger generation that
you know actually meaningful
relationships are very important and and
finding deep connection is is something
that they desire
um at the same time though you know
there's there's a lot of good research
on like family formation and tension uh
fertility intention for example
um over the last hundred years
and it actually hasn't changed that much
uh uh on average people today want about
three kids um and that's been that was
the same for our grandparents generation
right
um what I think has changed is uh uh the
means by which people achieve that
um you know there's a lot of social
scaffolding sort of cultural norms
around how you would date how you would
find a partner which have gone out the
window
um and you can't you know in my opinion
at least you can't sort of turn the
clock back on that but what you can do
is is move forward uh and use the
technology that we do have today to help
people achieve uh what they want in
terms of those goals I'm going to be
incredibly simplistic uh and you can
tell me that I'm wrong let's say I tell
keeper as a somebody who wants to find a
match uh that I would like in the future
to have three children would keep it
then automatically matching with with
someone who also wants three children or
is it a lot more complicated than that
um yeah so I mean you know typically it
it would be more than just a single
preference that people provide uh but if
that truly was you know your only
preference then that would be the one
that we met you based on
um but yeah I mean a number of kids uh
is is something we we collect from
everybody so there's sort of two
categories right there's things we ask
everybody and then there's uh we we give
our users the opportunity to just tell
us what they want
um uh and so that's where you know
things get really interesting that's
where you have uh natural language
processing like GPT style uh AI kind of
handles that in the way a human would
um but yes if if you know your one of
your preferences is to have three kids
uh we'll typically only match you with
people who also want three kids
um there is some gray area with with
this stuff so you know if if we have
your your dream woman on 99 of your
criteria but this one thing is off and
maybe she wants two kids instead of
three or something like that you know
there is room to kind of uh uh have the
AI generate a question for her you in
terms of like how flexible are you on
this or if we did find your dream person
but they only wanted two kids instead of
three like would you still want that so
uh that is the challenge of it right is
is
um people are are not black and white in
terms of their preferences but they do
generally want what they want and so
threading that needle is is uh uh you
know what what we're focused on on
building from an automation standpoint
do you think that the the AI or the
algorithm whatever it is knows uh what
people want more than they know so does
it work on information beyond what they
are telling you and how does it do that
yeah for sure that's a great question so
um the short answer is yes uh uh it will
get much better at that in the long run
you know the bigger our data set is the
more information we have on uh
successful matches and failed matches in
the past
um this is something that incumbent
dating apps uh actually do have quite a
bit of data on and
um you know that's an advantage that
they have
um
but uh we we do use uh basically like
psychology research
um uh there's a lot of research on uh
you know what traits indicate successful
long-term relationships there's also a
lot of research on uh what traits men
and women on average are tend to be
attracted to and in a partner
um and some people you know are very
upfront about these preferences or they
understand themselves and some people uh
you know are more shy to kind of share
them and so
um we'll make some assumptions uh
basically if you don't share them uh
we'll also we also might give you some
pushback right if you're a six foot
three woman and you say you want a five
foot two man like maybe but you know
that on average that's typically not the
norm and so we'll just make sure that
that's actually what you want
um so there it's again it's it's a very
uh it's none of this is black and white
um it's sort of handling different
scenarios uh based on what comes but we
do you pull a lot from the research the
research literature in the long run uh
we're gonna gonna be making assumptions
based on our own data set and what our
AI learns from it and I mean is it sort
of cheesy of me to say uh that you do
people object to the idea that computer
science can can solve the mysteries of
the heart
yes for sure
um I think uh you know there's something
there's something that feels uh you know
human or or you know literally romantic
uh in what we're doing and so the idea
that you know you can
mathematically address these things I
think is is understandably unappealing
to a lot of people right
um uh
at the same time like I I sympathize
with that I I you know emotionally or
spiritually uh uh understand where
they're coming from
um but I think ultimately uh it is
solvable uh with with this stuff and you
know I I don't think the the emotional
negative reaction to it is is a strong
enough justification to not do it like I
I would rather live in a world where you
know you can sign up for a product and
be matched with the love of your life at
any point immediately
um like I think that would be an amazing
world uh one that I would rather live in
and what's your emotional response to
because you're doing the type of AI that
connects people uh but of course there's
another AI that's connected to the world
of dating which is to come up with
um AI that actually is the partner
um so that you can have a partner who's
a bot and will tell you all the things
you want to hear
um right how do you respond to that do
you find that creepy
um yeah I I think you know my emotional
response to that is is just it's kind of
sad I I think uh there's a lot of men
today who are already sucked into kind
of that world uh with you know porn
video games sort of these these uh uh
hyper stimuli that allow us to escape
from from The Real World uh and yeah I
mean I I think you know those it's kind
of uh there's a lot of lost souls out
there who who get trapped uh in that
um so yeah I think it's really sad I
think um you know I there might be very
specific edge cases where you know
somebody's just in such a bad situation
physically or what have you or like okay
maybe you know putting them on morphine
is better than better than forcing them
to suffer but I think uh there's you
know far more 99 of the guys that are in
that situation are not uh
in that category and so yeah I think
it's really sad it's not something that
um I would spend my time focused on
building I think uh you know real world
real real relationships are are the
meaningful route and the one that most
guys should Aspire towards and do you
find uh the preponderance of your
clients are men and am I right in saying
that you you charge men for using them
but you don't charge women is that right
um yeah so 55 of all of our users are
female uh we do charge
um some women uh right now we're set up
to to mostly focus on acquiring men as
the paid users we're kind of still
exploring that so it might change uh
here pretty soon
um but for now uh most of the matches we
make are are the men paying
Jake I think we'll end it there but uh
thank you very much for uh coming onto
the spectator TV
that's it for uh the week in 60 minutes
this week I hope you've enjoyed watching
it and found us to be your perfect match
uh don't forget to subscribe to our
YouTube channel again do that by
clicking that button at the bottom of
your screen and then tapping the Bell
icon to make sure you never ever miss an
episode
thanks very much for watching
come back next week
[Music]